hey guys it is the 26th of November
today my name is Jess McDowell and
here's the things that mess in gaming
square enix Montreal's tomb raider
spinoff lara craft go is getting a free
expansion this Thanksgiving the update
called the shard of Lights will feature
26 new levels alongside new monsters
costumes artifacts and gemstone curry
mix Montreal have also announced that
Lara Croft go will be forty percent off
on the App Store Google Play Store and
windows marketplace so if you haven't
had a go at it yet now is probably a
good time PlayStation UK boss Fergal
gara has resigned and is now working for
Amazon as director of PC sony explained
that gaara opted to pursue a new
professional venture after spending four
years at the helm of PlayStation UK as
managing director PlayStation Europe
lost Jim Ryun praised the outgoing exact
same gaara has significantly
strengthened the bread and made
countless contributions to our success
we are extremely grateful for its
dedication and for the legacy that he
leaves warrick life who is currently
general manager of PlayStation across
the Nordics and East Europe will be
appointed as gaara's successor finally
after a hell of a lot of technical
issues the rainbow 6 beta has reopened
after its initial delay due to what you
Vsauce called issues with matchmaking
times and the disconnection on all
platforms servers for all platforms were
taken down for maintenance a blog post
on ubisoft's website explains game
sessions are not starting properly and
we've encountered server issues leading
to failed connection we've identified
the root issue that was introduced after
the technical test while fixing a
separate aspect of the game a fix is
currently under test and will be
deployed within the next few hours at 11
30 EST this morning you be announced the
beta would be back open again at 12
midday so you should be able to crack
into it now if you've been waiting on it
let me know down in the comments what
mattered to you too
and we should head to games but we've
got stories on a new Star Wars movie
teaser and heaps of black friday deals
that is everything I have for you today
but be sure to come back same time
tomorrow for the best gaming stories of
the whole week I will catch you then